all right so again he's trying to create
space with a trachea push okay so he
pushes I yield it okay and it's trapped
now get try to get your left arm out
it's trapped okay and so now he's trying
to create space by pushing on the hip
pushing up come on dude use your there
you go okay so I yield again when he
pushes come on underneath and I walk
around and now both his hands are high
they can't defend the mount okay he
might use his knees but you have more
hands than him so I come over and I keep
the arm crossed face okay can you get
your arm out no all right and that's
when I reach over however I need to can
you get your arm out no no I bring it
into place there is the
Goku my weight is on a h elbow tricep
tendent of insertion and for training I
gently apply pressure till he Taps okay
yes
sir try it